hi and welcome to Kaiba Max's Oscar
fever we've got that fever we don't feel
good I hurt my hand game and I both
really want to win Oscars big time so
even though we aren't officially
nominated there's still room for two
black horses to come from behind so
please consider our official submission
to win two Oscars for acting thanks for
agreeing to come and see me in our lab
dr. game no problem lieutenant max this
has been building for a long time and we
only have 12 hours to save it it's a
shame the cancer doesn't work on a
timetable cancers and inglorious bastard
I am a serious man but this whole drama
really caught me by the blindsides
fighting this Shore has been an
education for my crazy art my future is
up ultimi era but now I just noted
treasure what's precious you just needed
a push from your friend sapphire it's
not novel that she is so great sometimes
I just feel like I'm in our honor I see
you Jake Sully game before we do this I
just need to know one thing can you
handle the truth this disease is real
max and you are being a real dancing
baby about this from ally mcbeal cancer
should just eat my shorts man
Boston Public
hey Oscar phone for us Sunday mar 7